welcome breasts I'm really glad you
could join us here today thank you thank
you Andrew so you know today you're the
director of research at Apple and you
also have a faculty and professor Rowan
County mother University so I'd love to
hear a bit about your personal story how
did you end up doing this you know deep
learning work that you do yeah it's it's
actually does some extent it was I
started in deploying to some extent by
luck I did my master's degree at Toronto
and then I took a year off I was
actually working in the financial sector
it's a bit surprising and at that time I
wasn't quite sure where they want to go
for my PhD or not and then something
happened something surprising happened I
was going to work one morning and I bump
into Jack Hinton and Jeff told me hey I
have this terrific idea come to my
office I'll show you and so we basically
work together and he started telling me
about you know these Boltzmann machines
and contrastive divergence and some of
some of the tricks which I didn't at
that time quite understand what he was
talking about but that really really
excited that was very exciting and
really excited me and then basically
within three months I started my PhD
with Jeff so so that was that was kind
of like the beginning because that was
back in 2005-2006 and this is where you
know some of the regional deploying
algorithms using restrictive Boltzmann
and supervised spec training were kind
of popping up and so you know that's
that's how I started it was really you
know that one particular morning when I
bumped into Jeff completely changed my
my future career moving forward and then
in fact you were a co-author on you know
one of the very early papers on
restricted Boltzmann machines there
really helped with this resurgence of
neural networks and deep learning tell
me a bit more what that was like you're
working on that seven oh yeah this was
this was actually a really this was
exciting year I was a first year it was
my first year as a PhD student and
Jeff and I we're trying to explore these
ideas of using restricted Boltzmann's
and and using pre-training tricks to
train multiple layers and specifically
we will try to focus on autoencoders you
know how do we do an only an extension
of PCA effectively and it was very
exciting because we've got these systems
to work on em these digits which was
exciting but then the next steps for us
were to really see whether we can extend
these models to dealing with phases so
remember we had this automated phases
data set and then we started looking at
can we do compression for document so we
started looking in all these different
data you know real-valued count binary
and throughout you know a year it was I
was a first-year PhD students it was a
big learning experience for me but and
really within six or seven months we
were able to get really interesting
results and really good results
something that we you know we were able
to train these very deep autoencoders
this is something that you couldn't do
at that time using sort of traditional
optimization techniques and then it's
you know it turns out it's a really
really exciting paper for us that was
that was super exciting year because it
was a lot of learning for me but at the
same time the results turn out to be you
know really really impressive for what
we were trying to do so in the early
days of this resurgence of deep learning
or a lot of the activity was centered on
restricted Boltzmann machines and then
people see machines as a there's still a
lot of exciting research they're being
done including some in your group but
what's happening with both machines yeah
that's it that's a very good question I
think that in the early days the way
that we were using restricted Boltzmann
machines is you sort of can imagine
training a stack of these restricted
both machines that would allow you to
learn effectively one layer at a time
and there's a good theory behind you
know when you add a particular layer it
improves the variation bound and so
forth under certain conditions so there
was a theoretical justification and
these models were working
well in terms of being able to
pre-trained these systems and then
around 2009/2010 once the computer
started showing up you know GPUs then a
lot of us started realizing that
actually directly optimizing these deep
neural networks was you know was giving
similar results or even better results
so just standard back problems out the
pre-training or restricted Boltzmann
machine that's right that's right
and that's sort of over you know three
or four years and it was exciting to the
whole community because people thought
that wow you can actually train these
deep models using these pre training
mechanisms and then you know with more
compute people start realizing that you
can just basically do standard back
propagation something that we couldn't
do back in 2005 or you know 2004 because
it would take us months to do it on CPUs
and so that was that was a big change
the other thing that I think that we
haven't really figured out what to do
with you know both machines and deep
Boltzmann machines I believe they're
very powerful models because you can
think of them as generative models you
know they try to model complex
distributions in the data but when we
start looking at learning algorithms
learning algorithms right now they
require using you know Markov chain
Monte Carlo in variational learning and
such which is not a scalable as back
propagation algorithm so so we get have
to figure out more efficient ways of
training these models and also the use
of convolution it's something that's
fairly difficult to integrate into these
models I remember some of your work on
on using provost ik max pooling for sort
of building these generative models of
different objects and using these ideas
of convolution was also very very
exciting but at the same time it's still
extremely hard to train these models so
it's unlikely Israel yes how much these
work right and so we still have to
figure out water I on the on the other
side some of the recent work using
variational encoders for example which
could be viewed as directed versions of
Boltzmann machines we have figured out a
ways of of training these models was a
work by Maxwell and in there there
Kingma on using you know we pair with
relation tricks and now we can use back
propagation algorithm within the
stochastic system which is which is
driving a lot of progress right now but
we haven't quite figured out how to do
that in in the case of Boltzmann machine
so so that's a very interesting
perspective I actually wasn't aware of
which was in an earlier era where
computers were slower that the RPM you
know the pre-training was really
important as only fast the computation
that that drove switching to standing
back from you know in terms of the
evolution of the community is thinking
in deep learning another topic I know
you spent a lot of time thinking about
this the generative unsupervised versus
supervised approaches do share bit about
how you're thinking about that has
evolved over time yeah I think that's a
that's a really I feel like it's a very
important topic particularly if we think
about unsupervised or semi-supervised or
generative generative models because to
some extent a lot of successes that
we've seen there recently is due to
supervised learning and back in the
early days unsupervised learning was was
primarily viewed as unsupervised pre
training because we didn't know how to
train these multi-layer systems and even
today if you're working in a settings
where you have lots and lots of
unlabeled data and a small fraction of
labeled examples you know these
unsupervised pre training models so
building these generative models can
help you know for for supervised die so
I think that a lot of us in the
community you know it's kind of less it
was the belief when I started doing my
PhD was all about generative models and
try to learn these stacks of ball
because that was the only way for us to
train these systems today there is a lot
of work right now on generative modeling
you know if you look at generative
adversarial Network
if you look at variation within quarters
the energy models is something that my
lab is working on right now as well I
think it's it's very exciting research
but we haven't perhaps we haven't quite
figured it out again for many of you who
are thinking about getting in the
deploying field this is one area that's
I think we you know will make a lot of
progress and hopefully in the near
future so unsupervised early
unsupervised learning right head laying
oh maybe you can think of it as
unsupervised learning or semi-supervised
learning where you have I give you some
hints or some examples of what what
different things mean and I throw you
lots and lots of unlabeled data so you
know thank you very important insight
that in an earlier era of deep learning
where computers just slower the
restricted Boltzmann machine and deep
Boltzmann stream that was needed for
initializing the neural network weights
but as computers got faster straight
backprop then start to work much better
so you know one of the topic that I know
you've spent a lot of time thinking
about is the supervised learning versus
generative models unsupervised learning
approaches so how has your tell me a bit
about how you're thinking on that debate
has evolved over time I think that we
all believe that we should be able to to
make progress there it's just it's just
you know you know all the work on
Boltzmann machines variational t
encoders yes you can think a lot of
these models as generative models but we
haven't quite figured out you know how
to you know really make them work and
how can you make use of logic almost and
even if even for I see a lot of an IT
sector you know companies have lots and
lots of data
lots of unlabeled data there's a lots of
efforts for going through annotations
because that's the only way for us to to
make progress right now and it seems
like you know we should be able to make
use of unlabeled data because it's you
know it's just abundance of it and and
we haven't quite figured out how to do
yet so you mentioned for people wanting
to enter deep learning research you know
unsupervised learning the exciting area
today there are a lot of people wanting
to enter a deep learning either research
or applied work so for this global
community either researcher of my work
what advice would you have yes I think
that one of one of the key advisors I
think I should give is people entering
that field I would encourage them to
just try different things and not be
afraid to try new things and not be
afraid to try to innovate I can give you
one example which is when I was a
graduate student you know we were
looking at neural nets and he's a highly
non convex systems that are hard to
optimize and I remember talking to my
friends with in the optimization
community and the feedback was always
that well there is no way you can solve
these problems because these are non
convex we don't understand optimization
how could you ever even do that you know
compared to doing comics optimization
and it was surprising because in our lab
you know we never really cared that much
about those specific problems we just
were thinking about how can we optimize
and whether we can get interesting
results and that effectively was driving
the community so we're not were you know
we were we were not scared maybe to some
extent because we didn't maybe because
we were lacking actually the theory
behind optimization but but I would
encourage people to just try and not be
afraid to try to tackle hard problems
yeah and I remember you once said don't
learn to code just into high level you
know deep learning frameworks but
actually understand yes that's right I
think that bolon it's one of the things
that I try to do it when I teach you
deep learning class is is is one of the
for one of the homeworks I'm asking
people to actually code backpropagation
algorithm for convolutional neural
networks and it's you know it's painful
but but at the same time if you do it
once you really understand how these
systems operate and how they work and
how you can efficiently implement them
on on on GPU and I think it's it's
important for
you too when you go into research or
industry you have a really good
understanding of what these systems are
doing so it's it's important I think you
know since you have both academic
experience that's professor and
corporate experience I'm curious if
someone's sensitive learning what are
their pros and cons of doing a PhD
versus joining a company yeah I think
that's that's actually a very good
question in my particular lab I have a
mix of students some students want to go
and take an academic route some students
want to go and take an industry route
and it's it's becoming very challenging
because you can do amazing research in
industry and and you can also do amazing
research in academia but in terms of
pros and cons in academia I feel like
you have more freedom to work on long
term problems or if you think about some
crazy problem you can work on it so you
have a little bit more more freedom at
the same time the research that you're
doing industry is also very exciting
because in many cases you can with your
research you can impact millions of
users if you develop you know a core AI
technology and and obviously within the
industry you have much more resources in
terms of compute and be able to you know
do really amazing things so there are
pluses and minuses that it really
depends on on what you want to do and
right now it's interesting very
interesting environment where academics
move to industry and then you know focus
on industry move to academia but not as
much and so it's it's you know it's it's
it's a very it's very exciting times it
sounds like your academic machine
learning is great and corporate machine
learning is great and the most important
thing is just jumping right either one
just jump in so it really depends on
your own your preferences because you
can do amazing research in either place
so you've mentioned
supervised learning as one exciting
frontier for research are there other
areas that you consider exciting
frontiers for research yeah absolutely I
think that what I see now community
right now in particularly deep learning
community is there are a few trends one
particular area that I think is really
exciting is the area of deep
reinforcement learning because we were
able to figure out how we can train Ages
in virtual worlds and this is something
that's in just the last couple of years
you see a lot a lot of progress of how
can we scale these systems how can we
develop new algorithms how can we get
ages to communicate to each other with
each other and and it's I think that
that area is and generally the the
settings where you're interacting with
the environment is super exciting the
other area that I think is really
exciting as well is the area of
reasoning and natural language
understanding so can we build dialogue
based systems can we build systems that
can reason that can read text and be
able to you know answer questions
intelligently I think this is something
that a lot of research is is focusing on
right now and then there's not a sort of
sub-aerial so is this area of being able
to learn from fewer examples so
typically you know people think of it as
one short learning or transfer learning
a setting where you know you you learn
something about the world and I throw
you a new task at you and you can solve
this task very quickly much like humans
do without requiring lots and lots of
labeled examples and so this is
something that's a lot of us in the
community are trying to figure out how
we can how we can do that and how can we
have come closer to human-like
human-like learning abilities Thank You
Russ for sharing all the comments and
inside so there's especially if you say
hearing the story of your early days
dude thanks Andrea yeah thanks for
having me